hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll those of you
who have read my book in the big picture
will remember that I talked a lot about
consciousness not so much how
consciousness works but the fact that it
doesn't need any mystical spooky stuff
to go ahead and eventually explain it we
don't understand the explanation yet but
we have every reason to think that we'll
get there in perfectly physical natural
terms so one of the things you have to
establish if that's an argument you're
gonna make even though we don't yet have
the explanation is that it's possible to
imagine a purely naturalistic
explanation and part of that is
understanding how consciousness could
have arisen and of course consciousness
is an incredibly complicated
multifaceted thing so it's not one
simple answer there are stages along the
way so I talked in the big picture about
an example given by today's guest Malcom
McIver who was a professor at
Northwestern University about one of the
steps that conscious creatures might
have gone on in particular when fish
climbed on to land now obviously there's
a lot of physiological changes when you
go from being an aquatic animal to a
land-based animal but McIver claims that
there's also intellectual changes
there's changes in how you think and
it's based on the idea that how we think
is strongly influenced by how we sense
which is in turn related if you want to
the podcast I did with Lisa
Aziz a day on embodied cognition where
we talked about how how we think is
influenced by our bodies in general here
on today's podcast we're going to be
thinking about how thinking is
influenced by how we sense the world so
whether it's through our eyes or our
ears or in the case of certain fish they
have electrical impulses that give them
a handle on the world around them so
behind fur argues that the transition of
climbing onto land gave not only a
different way of thinking about the
world and looking at the world but a
different mode of imagination so not
only could you see much further
once you've climbed going to land but
that fact about your sensorium led
directly to an evolutionary change in
how you could compete for
food and other resources namely you
could plan ahead suddenly there is an
evolutionary pressure to develop a
capacity for imagination which is
crucial on the road to consciousness
so in today's podcast we dive into this
idea we talk about how we sense in
general how we think and then the
implications of this understanding for
how we should think how we can better
improve our actual cognitive capacities
both as individuals and as a species as
societies how we can plan for the future
we are stuck with the brains that
evolution gave us can we do better than
that so it's a wonderful conversation
mixing ideas from science and philosophy
with real implications for how we live
in the world let me also mention which I
like to do occasionally that you know
there's a web page for the mindscape
podcast I have a feeling that a lot of
listeners never go to the web page
that's perfectly fine but if you do
you'll find not only show notes and
links to important things but entire
transcripts of the episodes those
transcripts are of course paid for by
our supporters on patreon and PayPal
also on the web page you can find links
to become a supporter yourself throw
some cash at the mindscape podcast so
the web page is preposterous universe
calm which is my website in general
slash podcast we'd love to see you there
there's also little discussions you can
leave comments and all the episodes and
with that let's go
[Music]
Malka MacGyver welcome to - Kate podcast
great to be here so we have a lot of
ground to cover from you know fish
swimming around to planning for the
future of humanity and but you're a
somewhat complicated guy and you're a
wonderful role model for a successful
interdisciplinary career being as you
are professor in engineering departments
and yet working on all sorts of things
so maybe in in contrast with some other
people you might have on the show why
don't we talk a little bit about how you
got here like what was your academic
path that led you to where you are now
okay it's a very tortured path I guess I
began for all I didn't go to the formal
school was sort of self-taught
eventually got myself into Community
College in Canada and used that to get
in a university and they're essentially
curious about everything and I
immediately figured out if I did a
philosophy degree I could sort of get to
do every it's like everything yeah yeah
and but then two years into my degree I
started getting quite worried that I
might not be able to find a job so I
added a major in computer science
sounds good and something very
interesting happened I started taking
classes in philosophy and computer
science which we're talking about the
same things like turning machines and
philosophy of mind and the nature of
computation that I cut me very excited
because suddenly the thing that I
thought I was doing for you know a bread
a meal ticket was actually
intellectually also satisfying for me
and so that sort of led to this whole
line in in Cox I and AI that had pursued
for a while I started a two-year I did a
master's in philosophy science did a
two-year stint of a four-year program
ph.d program in cogs I and philosophy of
mind at Indiana University which is
actually whereas classmates with Dave
Chalmers and Anthony Romero and some
other people who've gone on to do really
well but two years into that I decided I
was getting kind of frustrated just
thinking about the nature of the mind
and thinking about the nature of
computation wanting to do something with
my hands as it were and
to reapply to grad school and get into
neuroscience and that's eventually led
to this program at Urbana University
Illinois in Urbana where I did
essentially Neurath ology but with a
strong computational bent you have to
tell me what neurology okay so it's the
it's the study of the neural basis of
natural behaviors as a very long and
ancient on that well maybe not ancient
tradition but old tradition out of
essentially the marriage of ethology and
neurophysiology do you know ethology oh
it was a study bound with behavior
Tinbergen will be looking at birds
rolling eggs konrad lorenz these are
famous even though those names I didn't
know the I didn't know the whole Greek
word yeah yeah so so just the letter e
not a ye or anything crazy like that
ethology yeah just to see thorgy so
those two fields got together in in
neuroethology and the pursuit of
neurology is one of looking at you know
things like predator prey behaviors any
kind of behavior see in in the natural
world
so rather than bringing an animal into
the lab and do what is effective for
creating scientific measurements
repeatability you you take what you get
in nature or you try to recreate it in
the lab and so that's there's a whole
tradition there and and that's what I
pursued except it was a lab run by a
former high energy physicist who was at
Caltech actually did a lot of work in
quarks mark Nelson as so many people are
former energy for the hilarious so as a
result it was a really interesting mix
of both you know animal behavior and
computational modeling and really highly
quantitative neurophysiology so it was a
really great training for me okay and
none of this is engineering none of this
is engineering so where engineering came
in is that you know last few years of my
PhD I was getting more into devising
actually we devised from the very first
perhaps the first robot that used the
same principles as weak electric fish to
sense objects these electric fish are an
actual kind of fish
yeah actual kind of fish not they don't
get plugged in they are there are real
animals that essentially emit a small
electric field and detect objects sort
of like it that uses sonar to detect
objects so that's what my PhD was on was
on characterizing their sensory system
and modeling natural behavior pre
capture behavior an electric fish as
they hunted their favorite prey which
happened in this particular species to
be water fleas and so but near the end
of my PhD I got into building robots
that duplicated some aspect of their
capability in in this particular case it
was how they use electric fields to
detect objects the kind of identify
objects the underlying theme here is
trying to figure out how thinking or
cognition relates to the body and the
biology well well the the theme of I
guess nerese near ethology is the most
effective angle into understanding
neural circuitry which is a lot more
conserved across animals and we
previously understood but so you can
study a fish you can study even insects
and get a lot of insight into neural
organization in general so the idea is
to use behaviors which were highly
selected for as levers into the
circuitry that supports those behaviors
okay and so that's that's really what
electric fish as a field is sort of
oriented around and the great thing
about electric fish which is why my
advisor and many other people with
quantitative or physics or electrical
engineering backgrounds have gotten into
them is that where as with most sensory
systems for example for a whole faction
it'd be very hard to give a step impulse
so you you can't really go from no order
to a full odor to no odor
there's just all this complex mixing
going on with electric fields when
you're when you're working on electric
fish it's trivial to take their field
add a sinusoidal modulation or a square
wave modulation and then look at what
their brain is doing as a result so you
can apply all of these techniques from
Electrical Engineering and systems
analysis theory to electric fish with
very little chopping so these are real
fish how big is an electric fish the
ones that are typically studying lab the
after nodes are 15 to 30 centimeters
long and do you is there a you know
vibrant black market and electric fish
market well what's funny is that they're
they're actually popular in the tropical
fish market and a lot of people get them
not even knowing that they are electric
fish they they have a bizarre body form
because they don't most fish swim by
flapping their tails these guys have
undulating membranes at the bottom of
their bodies we call it the ventral fin
and they undulate that sort of like a
curtain to move forward and backward and
frequently you can't tell what direction
they're swimming and they swim equally
Angele in both directions it's not
electric eel that's something different
electric eels are related they're
actually in in a in a close phylogenetic
relationship to the ones I'm telling you
about but they have evolved a much
stronger electric organ which can put
out 600 volts at an app to stun their
prey and then they can have a you know a
leisurely time going around nibbling up
the things that are stunned
so the eels using electricity as a
weapon has a weapon fish is also a since
yeah and they also have the low voltage
type to do sensing with okay but the
weakly electric fish only have the low
voltage so you get these electric fish
you bring them to your lab and you put
them in a tank and you tap them and see
what happens yeah you depending on the
experiment I did a lot of behavior with
them we also did a primary afferent
nerve you see all of you where you're
actually modulating their electric field
you take their field you think you add
some sort of change to it that simulates
them swimming by a rock or a plant and
you feed that back into the tank okay
and so you're getting there was a brain
innovative that it totally is which is
it's
really remarkable you can do virtual
reality with very little difficulty with
an electric fish because they are
sensing electric signals which you can
modulate with perfect control all over
the body with is that their primary
input or they also have site amenities
they have they have eyes
they're often blurry and cataract by the
time we get them they don't seem to use
them very much the reports are I mean
the the the the rivers that they hunt in
are turbot so even in the daytime they
you can't see more than a few
centimeters under them so so it looks
like they're mostly used for is it safe
to come out yet is a dim enough to come
out and hunt at night they hunt at night
or is it time to go hide in the weeds
right because they're they're precious
little bucks exactly and they want to
stay leave although there's a whole
buzzy and electric civilization of like
200 species and many of them will hunt
no one toddlers they will hunt other
electric fish in fact many of the fish
we we get in lab have like several
inches of their tail missing because
they've been nipped and they have their
tails where their electric field is
strongest so it's like it's almost like
a lure or and they happen to have
evolved a way to regenerate their spinal
cord in that area which has been a
subject of much interest because
vertebrates regeneration of spinal cord
is obviously an important ability but
there's an electric arms race among
several different yes yes it totally is
an arm right arms race with many
underwater yes they the whole
pulses went from a union phasic to
biphasic you know all these different
modes of signaling to her sexual
speciation and it's an amazing story do
you know how recently this developed an
evolutionary I think it was memory
serves it was around 100 million years
ago that the that they branched off of
the non-electric osteoclast more so i
think it was as I should know this
better I'm being beaten out yes okay so
how did you Hornswoggle Northwestern
University into thinking this is
engineering well so I came to actually
here at Caltech
according and worked with Joel verdict
who's who's a great roboticist here and
we did really fun work now on making a
robotic replicas of the locomotion
system which turns out to have all kinds
of fascinating properties the locomotion
system of the of the fish so this ribbon
fin locomotion system which gives them
bi-directional motion forward backward
motion with amazing agility and so we
built a robot here several robots here
that replicated parts of the entire
ribbon fin essentially and we we had a
scale model I remember this first one we
did was with wheels and servo motors and
the the last one we did was quite long
was about a meter long we had it in a
flow tank in the basement of the
mechanical engineering building and did
a variety of fluid studies of it and is
it I mean it seems that having electric
fields as your primary sense working is
a weird thing in the animal kingdom yes
and also having this locomotion is a
weird thing among yes underwater
dwelling things is there a relationship
between there is a very tight
relationship and so the way it goes is
these these are animals which will yeah
typically when they're hunting you'll
see them hunt backwards you'll see them
hunt forwards there's a great advantage
to hunting backwards - moving backwards
well while hunting in that by the time
the prey or object of interest has
gotten to their mouth they've scanned it
with their electrosensory system so
because it's a really near field sense
you kind of need to stragety cross the
receptors of the body before you can
identify so if there's if they're
swimming backwards that's really easy
you know they've scanned it by the time
it gets to their head if they're
swimming forwards what they do is they
they do this sort of they'll they'll
rotate or something to get closer as
they're swimming forward then they'll do
a rapid corkscrew back that's sort of
back to get to get the object if it's
something that they want
so the relationship is that this
electric sense is very useful but a
short range it's short range and if they
were to try to if they only had a big
tail fin and they had to go forward and
circle around they would have lost the
prey because they can so i spent much of
my PhD quantifying exactly how far they
can sense the their their objects of
interest out to and for a you know 15
centimeter fish it's something on the
order of three and a half centimeters
for a millimeter sized prey you know so
they're hunting really these particular
species that were talking about which is
after notice alba fronds are hunting
really where the black goes much much
sexier named black goes my fish hunt
these millimeter sized water fleas and
so they can only sense those three and a
half centimeters or so away and so if
they were to swim forward and circle
back they would have told you boss came
over yeah now isn't this obvious
evidence in favor of intelligent design
the fact that the fish I bought this
locomotive mode and the electric field
complete mechanism yes or do we have an
evolutionary understanding at which came
first we it's a good question I I don't
know if we know from the fossil record
which came first I suspect because
undulatory swimming is actually not that
uncommon it wouldn't surprise me if that
might have come first but and and there
in fact there are these non electric
fish like Zeno Maestas Nigri which has a
ribbon pin and they use passive electro
sense but don't actively generate it
but again Paso electro sense is a super
short-range sense and so having a ribbon
fin that kind of goes with that so it
may not be active electro sense
dependent but it might have co-evolved
with either active or passive probably
passive first I think that's the
ancestral condition okay okay so you
worked on the locomotion aspect of the
electric fish as a postdoc here at
Caltech and then and that does sound a
little bit more engineering to me yeah I
like how things move in weird certain
phrases right right and so what what I
was trying to figure out what robot Asst
is called a small time reachable set of
the animal which is what you give
which is essentially where you can get
to given any feasible control input so
for a car you know you can go forward
and backward initially and with some
turning of your wheels you can kind of
get an hourglass shape and then you can
do parallel parking and such but you can
see how that shape evolves in your
mind's eye as you get more time right
from an kind of an hourglass shape to
more something like a circle and so I
was curious what this would be for
electric fish since this is actually
something that was actively being worked
on by some kind of geometric
differential geometry people who are
interested in the problem so say
mathematicians the matador field exactly
exactly
yeah well they were originally doing it
for current reform where the tail
flapping type swimmers okay and I wanted
to do it for ribbon fin swimmers and
that got me into oh well this is a motor
volume or as I now call it or small time
reachable set that has this very
interesting geometry at small time
scales that changes at larger time
scales and it has this very interesting
relationship to the sensory sensorium of
the of the fish
I sort of plus here because it is kind
of amazing to me the relationship
between motion maybe it's not that
surprising when I put in these words the
relationship between the motion of
objects and organisms and differential
geometry and high automatics remember
there was a vividly there's this
wonderful little book on differential
geometry by Walter Burke where he does
the he gives an explanation for why
people are find it difficult to get an
intuitive grasp of parallel parking
ah-ha he says it's because it involves
the non commutation of vector field yeah
yeah exactly because you have the
operation of moving forward or back and
you have the operation of turning your
wheels right or left and they don't
commute it right matters we have to do
first yeah and if you understand that
perfectly well it helps you parallel
park exactly and so I can see why if you
had different modes of moving the
differential geometry would become
interested yeah yeah and so that got you
interested in differential geometry or
it got me very interesting different of
geometry although I didn't pursue it too
at about that time I got this multiple
people emailed me this sort of job um
that was opening up at Northwestern that
was looking for a neurobiologist also
trained in engineering and I see yeah so
so my I cut Mike my postdoc about it
year short just as I was getting into
the more arcane and interesting aspects
of the differential geometry approach to
these animals so so but it did get me
interested in how to understand the
relationship between sensory spaces
since Oriya of the animal and their
locomotion ability which has led to many
interesting avenues subsequently right
so once you're at Northwestern you're
still studying the electrical fish yeah
but you become I mean it sounds like
from the story that you had some initial
interest in thinking you know how the
nervous system was working cuz I'm gonna
sit in the sort of warm mechanical
exactly it's emotive ass yeah yeah and
now you're a faculty member you can do
whatever you want and so you start
thinking more about thinking in the
right system yeah yeah and so the way
that went was roughly speaking I so the
the last bit of my postdoc was paper
characterizing exactly how these sensory
and motor volumes coordinate over
different time scales and at the end of
at the end of this work I decided it
would be fun to look at how visually
guided animals underwater how they how
they coordinated their sensory spaces
with their local motor spaces so in
particular so sorry you'd figured out
some relationship between this very
special weird thing yet be steeped
electric - yeah that can they can sense
a certain distance around it using
electric fields yes and you related it
to this weird locomotive think it has
precisely so you want to know okay what
the non weird yeah that relationship
well right and so just you know to
quickly summarize the electric fishes
sensory volume looks like a cylinder
around their body okay and their small
time reachable set or their motor volume
is essentially cylinder as well
how they get that cylinder out of their
actuator is a really interesting problem
which we solve but I won't go into the
details but then the question is for an
animal that looks forward and so now
imagine in your mind's eye sort of a
pie-shaped wedges space in front of them
and then they have a tail flapping
system that only pushes them forward
into that space into that wedge of space
and they can y'all or turn left and
right roughly proportional you know
somewhat related to their the the the
angle of that pie you know so PI slice
and so I was interested in
characterizing how those two things
coordinated in a visually guided animal
and so we did the calculations and some
estimates and turned out that there's I
expected I guess to see something you
know we walk around with this giant
sensory volume or cell visual sensory
volume and my intuition was that that
visually guided fish underwater would
have this giant pie wedge thing that
they would be moving around looking for
their prey and it turned out to be
really pathetically small and so small
that I thought they were there was an
error in the calculation which one was
small the pie that the length of the pie
but so how far I lied the Sasori umpires
locomotion by the sensorium pie so these
visually got it fish hunting for small
bugs don't see them very far ahead and
it was such a small distance ahead I
thought there was a problem with the
calculations but I can Juli Airy quickly
they get far yeah I can't see far
correct and I thought this can't be
right because in fact what matters food
for all of these animals is not the the
static volume but the sweat volume
through time so as you you know because
they're searching for empty space or
relatively empty space for or food for a
live prey and it turns out the sweat
volume for the electric fish was almost
identical to this pie wedge-shaped
sweat volume that the the the visually
guided fish have the shape was different
but the shape was different this volume
was almost the same okay now electric
fish have to pay for every jewel of the
energy that they're investing in
electric field whereas visually guided
fish are parasitizing the sun's
so there's a difference there in the
bioenergetics but that let's be a
coincidence that these two very
different organisms using two very
different mechanisms have evolved the
same sensory volume it's it was
bizarrely similar in size to me but so
eventually I nailed down that that it's
simply due to the attenuation length of
light and water so it turns out that
water is a terrible medium for for
seeing with libel and I just didn't you
know I guess people who do scuba diving
and and and work in submarines can tell
you this from their experience that
suddenly things appear out of nowhere
but you know I didn't have that that
experience but so so the numbers showed
really clearly and you lose a huge
amount of information on the order of
meters and that's imperfectly like
laboratory clear water it's not a
function of turbidity whit if you add
any particles in the water then your
range really goes down to nothing so
that led me to I was at that time
getting interested in what happened to
vertebrates at the water land transition
in the upper Devonian why did fish
evolve limbs and all the other things
they needed evolve to come up on the
land yeah you know what what was the
basis of that and it occurred to me that
vision must have changed greatly after
the water line transition because
suddenly you're going from a medium
which is like a huge thick blanket on
your sensorium to essentially infinity
right you can see a distance further
than is in most cases behaviorally
useful oh we could see the moon right
yeah so you know for prey on the moon so
so so well so what I was curious about
was the eyes of the ancestral aquatic
vertebrates were pretty small and I
expected that they got as big as would
be useful in this highly attenuating
medium and you can calculate it out and
we've done that and they are about as
big as they should be the eyes of a fish
yeah because getting them bigger
essentially your visual range is poor
Colonel DRI sighs but are the eyes of a
whale really big I don't know the size
of the eyes of a whale they usually use
their echolocation systems for range
okay because the attenuation length of
sound in water is similar to the
attenuation length of light in air and
so whales and dolphins are really
interesting example of vertebrates that
got used to giant visual sensoria doing
the one thing that you could do in water
to regain that kind of range interest
which is use the high-frequency sound
production system that that land animals
generated
do it for imaging I know this about this
are there underwater animals that use
echolocation that are not former land
animals not to my knowledge
or maybe like one or two species of
these teal EOS that use clicks I'm fuzzy
on remembering the species but I think
that there might be a couple of examples
now de leus are very recently evolved
animals but there so there might be that
case but anyway the ancestors of
dolphins and whales we've got you know
used to this look jewelry yes
for all its we have seen the whole world
and they somehow cleverly figured out
how to reproduce it exactly yeah and so
now you asked me a long time ago about
houses connect to thinking and I'm very
interested in a relationship between how
far away you can sense objects and how
you modulate your behavior so the
intuition there is just think of
yourself driving rapidly too rapidly
down a foggy Road and you see something
suddenly you don't have a lot of
executive planning that's going to go
into deciding what to do next
you're gonna swerve you're gonna break
but in any case you're gonna do
something simple and so my thought was
that it was be central to the evolution
of more complex cognition to be able to
sense things far enough out where it
makes sense to actually have a plan and
the whole reason I was driven to sort of
do a whole but
of analysis of what happened division
once we got into land was an interest in
why it is that vertebrate brains got a
lot more complex substantially more
complex once we came up on land so the
idea is that underwater you might
imagine from our you know a very
parochial air land-based point of view
that thinking ahead of time is just a
very useful skill to have yeah but it
also has costs yes right you know energy
and yes volume in our brains and so cams
and you're saying it for a fish it just
doesn't help
yeah no point what Lenny had too much
you you you you can do it and they do do
it to some extent it's just that it's
much much more useful once you come up
on land and energetically I mean it's a
gift like as soon as you bend that
cornea that was inappropriate after you
came out of the water you need to bend
it a little bit for the different
refractive index but as soon as you fix
that which can be done very rapidly
evolutionarily speaking you now can see
hundreds of body lengths away and
suddenly you go from an animal which was
trapped in kind of a reactive bubble
sort of always driving in the fog if you
will to an animal which may not have had
the neural circuitry initially for
anything other than reactive control to
an animal which with the right mutations
might be able to stall the issuing of
motor commands to the motor system and
movement towards a prey to think about
you know well if I do option a you know
the prey will run away but if I do
option B the prey won't run away so
maybe I'll do option B but wait a minute
mean this is there's a fraud set of
words you're using here right it's not
only planning ahead it's also using some
sort of imagination absolutely for that
ability to simultaneously contrite
different hypothetical yes scenarios in
your head yes and so you're saying that
the thing that prodded evolution to
develop that capability was climbing up
on do they are correct yes and so we now
know the address of that system in the
brain it's the hippocampus in
coordination with the frontal lobes that
you can actually now monitor animals
thinking ahead thinking about different
paths when they are given a challenging
situation we're putting them in an fMRI
machine well actually the the studies
I'm thinking of right now our ones on
what's called vicarious trial-and-error
in rodents and and those studies such as
out of radishes lab at the University of
Minnesota we're done with electrodes in
the brain looking at play cell activity
in the hippocampus play cells in the
hippocampus essentially are activating
activated according to where you are in
space and what they observed is in mazes
where there was not a reliable sort of
reward location where you'd switch it so
the animal had to sort of think about
what to do next then at choice points
you can actually see the play cells
racing down one arm of the maze or the
other arm of the maze before they act
well so they're pausing there and
they're thinking about different futures
and we're these parts of the brain there
and the fish and adapt you know so so
there is a part of the the dorsal
pallium so this is an area of increasing
interest to me because I'm certain I'm
not one to say that suddenly we had it
there had to be precursors of course and
fish have placed cells or have a sense
of home I should say they have a sense
of where they are in space they have
spatial maps they have cognitive maps in
brain so certainly they have some of the
primitive infrastructure for this but to
do planning to do imagination there's no
evidence we don't know of fish being
able to do this and that part of the
brain at the campus and of course
frontal areas and mammals got much much
larger well I know I mean I do know this
work that at least claims from the fMRI
studies that the part of the brain that
lights up when you ask someone in an
fMRI machine to imagine the future
circumstance is the same part roughly
speaking as when you imagine ask them to
conjure up memory of a black circum
so it seems to be out of well that the
existing circuitry for that kind of
thing right that that discussion comes
up in in sort of analyses of how our
parochial thought about memory
not quite right it's not like a random
access store it's more like a recipe
which once you recreate the experiences
in your sensory cortices you sort of
regenerate the experience that's where
that comes up but this is something a
little bit different this is there's
this the hippocampus is very very
special multimodal structure that binds
information across different modalities
and and does relationships really well
and that is where this imagination at
least is one core part of the
imagination circuit well that's always
the problem right like we use words that
were invented hundreds of years ago like
imagination yeah of course they have
different aspects going on in your brain
but he's saying pinpoint this particular
one and you think you can so that
there's a hypothesis yes that it's
related that the use of this to do this
hypothesizing and future planning is
related to this transition from seedling
press precisely right so we're now we
did this analysis of what happened to
vision from after the emergence from
water to land we did this we had a
hypothesis about what happened to the
eyes
turns out our initial hypothesis is
wrong we thought the eyes would blow up
in size after we gave up on the land and
it was much more interesting because we
saw a blow up and I sighs about ten
million years before we came up on the
land in the fossil birth in the fossil
record and it turns out at the very same
time Skull morphologies disclosed that
animals sort of had these flattened
skull shapes with these orbits way on
top of the skull table and the fur they
look all the world for like crocodiles
so what what would they have been doing
well it turns out there's this huge
bloom of invertebrate life on land at
that point 50 million years preceding
the vertebrate
water to land physicians in the plains
were already out there exactly yeah so
what we can then say is whereas in the
past we always thought of if you were to
ask what's the most useful body part for
getting for bringing us up onto land you
would have said well limbs and everybody
thought about the limbs and how did the
digits evolve and how do they separate
from well it turns out that the eye the
eye increased preceded that stuff like
the
separation of digits and all that stuff
was preceded by a big increase in eye
size so it looks like what might have
happened something more causally
interesting which is that I sighs grew
up and showed all this bounty that made
it worthwhile clambering up on the land
for and only after that point do you
start to see things like rib cages and
all these other things that you need to
live on land with and digits separated
digits all that came after the increase
in I saw some fish we're lucky enough to
realize that if they poked their eyes up
above the water they could see much
further yeah yeah got a tiny little yes
epsilon advantage yes and and therefore
their descendants whose eyes were more
capable well we have a theory about that
too there's a there are these breathing
holes that are now our eustachian tubes
that were right behind the eyes and we
were going through a very low oxygen
period of the earth history in the
Earth's history right at that point and
so we think the animals are actually
coming up for a breath of air okay and
just coincidentally yeah oh my goodness
bounty of unexploited food on different
food and we're so excited that we
actually started getting the fossil
records of the insects at the time and
you can see evidence for chemical
defense systems suddenly appearing in
the fossil record about the time that
the vertebrates came up on the land
chemical defense systems sollozzo pours
on millipedes have these chemical
defense systems which currently are
active against vertebrate predators and
they just pop up in the in the defense
before that I guess millipedes didn't
like eating other millipedes I'm not
really sure but all the other bugs that
were there apparently not a you know a
system that was needed before that time
okay so the the fish had this
evolutionary advantage some of them
figured this out yeah and and there was
this new pathway that opened up that
there was yet another evolutionary
advantage oh I can plan for the future
right so so alright thought has that and
now we're doing all these computational
simulations and and we were almost ready
to submit a manuscript that basically
shows that
if you have a small range small sensory
range and this is not exactly you know
mind-blowing stuff you would Intuit it
but if you have a small range planning
it's useless if you have a bigger range
planning becomes progressively more
useful I know people who have a small
range I'm not very good plan but so what
what was fascinating is after we did
those initial simulations these were all
in open world scenario so no clutter is
that we got to this plateau so this is
your simulation yeah simulation or
predator-prey yeah so we have a predator
and a prey and we're using Markov
decision processes to model the sort of
the game between the the predator and
prey and the prey has a thick sensory
range of predator as a infinite range
anyway we got to certain point where we
said you know this isn't very land like
and we're getting survivability rates
for our prey that are really quite low
and you know it seems like they ought to
do a bit better why don't we try putting
clutter in the space because that's what
land gives you is lots of clutter lots
of geometry it's not fun to play hide
and seek in an empty room exactly yes so
we've tried that and we saw a
fascinating pattern which was planning
became much much more useful but only in
a restricted range of clutter which
matches to rest your typical terrestrial
ranges so purely open space not very
much advantage for planning total
clutter where all you see is jungle and
forest also not very useful for planning
but there's a sweet spot mid level
entropy if you if you actually calculate
the entropy level of the the terrestrial
space of the clutter at mid-level
entropies you get this beautiful
increase in the advantage of planning
and that's because there's some much
more complex structure there in the
space of possibilities exactly so now so
so now what we see is that every time
the prey moves the value of that move
and the location that move is highly
contingent on the Predators location
because if there's an obstacle in front
of it it's got one value and if there's
open tear
to where the predator can just lunge
then it's got a totally different value
and so you this this diversity of values
that appear once you have clutter is
really what is exploited by planting
native any idea whether or not the first
fish to come up onto land did so in
moderately cluttered environments well
so there's lots of good data now on that
that forest systems were we're going at
that time so it's plausible anyway it's
possible yes okay for sure so that I
think that that's a convincing case that
once you're on land in the right
circumstances planning in some vague
sense is useful is it obvious that
evolution had the wherewithal to take
advantage of this new opportunity well
that's so it's clearly the case that it
did right okay so we do so do mammals
many other mammals and to do it's very
strong behavioral evidence that many
birds as well the neurophysiology is
lagging in that group of animals but so
it's there there's no question of it we
do plan we do we do we do the match in
futures some of us better than others ah
exactly and so part of this is what's
the archeology of that you know how did
it occur why did it occur and I'm
interesting that question from multiple
angles one is that I'd like to know why
are we so bad at planning whether it's
there's tight spatial and temporal
limits to our ability to plan it seems
very very constrained and escaping those
constraints might be incredibly useful
or or transcending them might be
incredibly useful in context such as
looming threats that are chance or
transformational like climate change or
you know possibly AI might be another
but in any case threats where action has
to be regulated behavior has to be
regulated across time scales that are
much longer than what we are natively
comfortable with our planning systems I
mean would you go so far as to relate
this emergence of the imagination if you
want to be slightly more patient yeah
yeah I don't know it's perfect perfect
word for it conscious
yes yes so I think that there's so from
my standpoint there's that's the most
productive way of thinking of
consciousness currently in terms of the
in terms of imagination
so the first animal that had to examine
its mental furniture in order to derive
a useful behavioral program the first
animal that had to imagine so eight so
that you're linking there we were
previously talked about planning in
terms of you know I could hide under the
tree or I could climb on the rock
etcetera
yeah but now there's a bit of
self-awareness well right well so but a
necessary part well it seems kind of
ineluctably connected in that it is in
your brain that you are examining these
futures you're part of the future and
you're part of that future right so of
course it's not everything want
everything that people want from the
word consciousness but I think
scientifically speaking what what is the
most of what at least for me what is
crucial is having something that is
actionable scientifically and from that
standpoint
the the idea that at least a core
component here of what we mean by
consciousness is this a magic space of
imagination that opens up for purely
adaptive very easily you know calculated
now we can show in the simulations why
it arises or why it would arise that
it's a perfectly natural response to a
challenge that is brought by the
interaction of long-range sensing visual
sensing with with this dynamic context
where memory is not quite sufficient
where you need to take into account
moment by moment positions of your
threats and act accordingly so having
that ecological scenario drives animals
to evolve the system where they examine
the contents of their own thoughts and
is this I mean I think that if we
conjured up your former classmate David
Chalmers here yeah he would
cast the hard problem of consciousness
in terms of what it is like to feel
something you know dread electively
first person's subjective experience
right
are you is that what you're addressing
here or you sort of know I like this is
like that this is a bit more objectively
right this is quite quite this is not
that that aspect of consciousness you're
you're in the still in the realm of what
David would would call the easy problem
yes if everyone agrees is hard yes yes
okay very good so and in fact I mean as
you know and Chalmers probably spoke to
of this and well has in many other
contexts of the Lisa that there's an
aspect of that which seems completely
outside of the capability science
because if science is supposed to be
interested then if this is something
that has to be subjective then it can
you know so therefore the ontology has
to grow etc and so yeah but that's way
beyond what I'm talking about I'm
talking about something very practical
which is the space of imagination where
we would ourselves figure in that
imagination and so that's the first
moment at which ourselves sort of became
a well an item of thought right no
self-awareness is clearly an important
aspect of anyone's definition of
consciousness and so that's what you're
you're getting it yeah and so I have to
ask the obvious question for anyone asks
what about the octopus yes never climbed
up Wonderland
so I finally I just recently wrote a
proposal to look at these guys we should
say octopuses are really really smart
well so that is so so so everybody who
looks at them carefully has told me you
know don't don't go so fast with that
because you know of course you hear
things about them looking at people
opening jars and then going and doing
the same but I've heard from the same
people who have done a lot of work on
them that you know they're able to do it
once and then they can't ever do it
again
they don't remember her well or that
exactly they got lucky or something like
this so I'm not I'm not denying that it
looks like they do there's such a thorn
in my side as soft as they are but no I
think I think there's something very
interesting going on there and and
here's here's a couple of odds one
octopus are this you know they're
they're nudibranch Mallis meaning
they're unshelled meaning they're
unarmored yeah and yet they're this
delicious protein that can't swim very
fast and they're hunted by the animals
with the greatest sensory range in the
water which are dolphins and whales
which have turned their sound production
systems into these amazing long-range
sonar systems so they have had to
survive by their wit's and furthermore
they're hunted by I just learned from
Roger Hanlon who's done a lot of work on
them that their their their prey preyed
on by diving birds who are also
extremely intelligent animals and can
see very long distances from above and
they typically hang out in shallow areas
and these birds dive and hunt them so
it's hard out here for an octopus so
it's really hard living as an octopus
because they don't have great escape
mechanisms they're great food so
possibly and this seems terribly hot
Hawk so I immediately grant that this
this may just be a completely different
way to evolve cognition than what the
land vertebrates have done but it is
interesting that that they are preyed
upon by some of the smartest vertebrates
and it is interesting that they have
these tremendous eyes although I would
argue because vision is so useless for
the most part at least has a long-range
sense in water that vision is giving
them things like acuity for manipulation
and that sort of thing they're not very
good at
well-said not that I should say they're
not very good at but the design of the
octopus brain as it were is utterly
different right totally different yeah
it's like spread out all throughout but
that's not necessarily you know so birds
also have a very very different design
for their brain but
they also seem to have something like a
hippocampus like structure and there's a
part of the octopus brain that people
have identified as being possibly
hippocampal okay in nature so one thing
that seems to be the case is that nature
is very good at evolving the correct
solution regardless of the starting
point so if you need a hippocampal like
structure then if you started off as in
vertebrate stock you'll come up with it
if that's what you need okay and so so
let's get back to the octopus cut that
out of the way octopus lovers out there
that was totally satisfy Nance I mean I
know that there look there are people I
know they're very smart
ethical people who won't eat octopus you
know because there's a certain level of
intelligence I think these are very good
questions I'm not dogmatic in any
direction about them I the idea what the
right thing to think is I'm hoping to
find out good good
we'll have you back when you find out
okay so back to the vertebra yes where
we live yes
so you have the hypothesis and the the
the hypothesis about the relationship
between imagination and climbing up on
the land so there's some evidence in the
fossil record that the evolution of eyes
did what you might expect it to do
exactly oh right
is there as their evidence one way or
the other for the evolution of brains
doing what you'd expect them to do well
that's tricky because they don't
fossilize and so what we can do is you
can do things like look at commonality
between the structure that is
hippocampal like in birds and in mammals
and their last common ancestor lived
about 50 million years after the water
to land transition okay so it's not so
so there's a big argument was it
parallel evolution was a convergent
evolution but yeah so it's it's really
hard to know how far back that goes from
the fossil record okay I'm gonna take
your time now
yeah because the song is going
[Laughter]
without
right because what we can't get actual
fossil records the best we can do is
look at the different things that are
alive today
exactly yeah roughly map them it's very
hard like it's hard because I'm buried
in the origin of life and you can think
about the simplest organisms that live
now and you might think well they're
closer to what life like when it started
but there's still billions of years away
well not only that so one of the places
we can look is at the kalium which is
the structure that's thought to be the
ancestral - hippocampus dorsal pallium
in particular and part of that and we
can look at inti Leo's fish and I have
colleagues of mine who've done this and
have found evidence for things like
spatial maps there and so on and so
forth a tricky thing there is that our
last common ancestor with those animals
was hundreds of millions of years ago
and so they've been busy evolving on you
know these all sort of potentially novel
structures more complicated and unique
in their own ways right so you have to
be careful about comparisons of extent
creatures to get at to reverse-engineer
or back calculate what happened a long
time ago so not to say it won't be
eventually possible there's increasingly
this realm of sort of recovering soft
body structure by a high cat but it's
essentially scanning imaging fossils
that were really well preserved and
people are starting to be able to see
neural structures that way and so maybe
eventually we'll be able to tell more
hippocampus is pretty deep in there so
at least for that structure I have to be
a bit skeptical but yeah um but
nevertheless we are gonna fearless
leader all conclusions from this line
totally human being yes yes yes so
there's the thought that if this story
is right whether or not it's right
there's the fact that our much beloved
and vaunted ability to plan and think
yes conscious yes is reliant upon what's
in our brains yes and if it did come
from like evolution does not have
teleology it doesn't aim toward the
future right it just responds to the
moment yeah and does that does this
story of how we got here have lessons
for where we are now yes and I think
the answer to that is yes and so that's
where the research is going right now is
is clearly we have some capacity to plan
for the future
but it seems to be both spatially
limited as in we don't think about
spaces very far away from us I'm not
thinking right now about a trail in
Africa I might go on in a few hours and
we don't think about things a very far
away in time either you know we might
stretch ourselves to think about our
retirement but not very good pretty bad
at that and then what are we gonna do
about problems that are you know
multi-generational such as climate
change right and so I'm very interested
in what the biological mechanisms are
for the setting the lengths of our
planning horizon so and and there's some
very interesting work going on right now
on that and and I'm hoping to contribute
to that I'd recently got a an award from
the NSF to look at this in mice with
with data I'm back at Northwestern where
we're gonna essentially study planning
in rodents and giving them a whole bunch
of challenging environments including
predator prey contacts and start to look
at what sets the time base of the
horizon so you know is it can we
extended by today today's or two weeks
or two it two months or is it something
that anything beyond a few minutes is
purely through cultural technology okay
so the idea is that you know the fish
naturally from evolution plans seconds
in advance yeah and once you find
Wonderland now its minutes minute as we
like the more time that it takes yeah
you see tens to a minute right okay but
clearly human beings can do a little bit
but yes dogs and cats can't now I'm
thinking about it I'm not even clear
that my cats can do seconds advance
right but we how can we do so many maybe
the first question is why can we even do
that well right I think that that we can
do better than that is interesting and
the way in which we can do it
as in its alt I'll call it affective
valence like how much we care about the
things we think about far in the future
or far in time I think it's very telling
and from that perspective the this Peter
thing has this great analogy of you know
I'm sure you've heard it singer's pond
this is this thought experiment of your
driving up you just bought a $5,000 suit
you're driving
by a pond you see a struggling child in
the pond what do you do of course you
get out of your car and you run into the
water destroy your suit well his
question is why don't you send the
$5,000 to save a child whose life would
clearly be saved yeah by that $5,000 who
lives in Africa and my answer to that
would be well your you have a very
carefully titrated system between your
care system your your planning horizon
and at all sort of meshes but it meshes
in very in a very local way and that
makes sense in terms of evolution why do
precisely and so getting beyond that I
think is a hard bargain at least in
terms of getting it natively with
circuitry so we can think about cultural
technology to do it but it'd be nice to
identify at least what's constraining us
in terms of biological mechanism so if
we wanted to in the future in the
scientific I Phi future to be able to go
in with electrodes or some sort of
neural prosthetic which would extend our
planning horizon that we could do so
right now we don't know enough about it
to know how we do it are there even
other animal species that do manifestly
plan weeks and events it depends on so
so yes there is a cache etc it depends
on so some of this can be sort of
assimilated to instinctual behaviors
that are genetically hard programmed and
so it's clear that the animal has no
explicit representation of this
occurring and they're just and if you
interfere with their routines it's very
easy to throw them off and they just
repeat right but so so I think squirrels
and birds and
and other mammals have seemed to
represent planning at least on the order
of days if not weeks for caching
purposes beyond that I think it gets
really fuzzy because of this issue of
could it be just genetically hardwired
right but doesn't so for humans doesn't
it make sense to think and he's just too
simplistic but I have this idea that you
know there was a phase transition we
became you know the the ability to
express ourselves abstractly and in
language now communally yeah that gave
us away maybe this would you mean by the
cultural artifacts yes I even just
individually I think that this gives us
an ability to conceptualize the future
that isn't just hardwired absolutely it
does and my but my suspicion is that the
that the gap between that kind of
rationality and our this sort of local
care system where where our native sort
of planning horizons mesh with care
where motivation also has a seat is kind
of the thing that we need to really
crack go in order to motivate ourselves
to regulate behavior to affect
timescales far outside of our natural
range so in other words you know so a
looming existential threat that might be
multi-generational in scope how do you
motivate yourself now to do X Y Z yeah
right and obviously we can have
something like the climate change panels
that are telling us we need to do this
now and governments be if they're
responsible will do that and impose
things like carbon taxes etc but on a
personal motivational level you know we
I guess that's that's where that gap can
start to to really affect us between the
natural sort of care system and the
cognitive system that a bunch of people
discussing this can say look we need to
now reduce our carbon footprint by this
amount or else right I do think that
there
is this maybe a little parenthetical and
off-track but that's okay that's why
we're here there's a question of how
much you should care about things in the
future or things right away right
exactly
I hate talent on the podcast and he I
called if he wasn't happy I called him
miss but I called him a temporal version
of Peter Singer yes because that's you
know advocating that we have essentially
a zero discount rate for caring about
the future and he had certain policy
recommendations that follows from that
that you can disagree with but the
interesting philosophy question should
we care about people far away and people
in the future just as much as read near
neighbors and our current selves
right so there's the enormity of
question and yeah of how we discount the
future and then there's the empirical
and empirically we are hyperbolic
discounters so we don't essentially so
explain what that means well so so the
value of a future harm or benefit
rapidly declines with distance from the
now right and the function that
describes that decline is hyperbolic 1rx
yeah right so so Cowan and others
there's there's others who are have
discussed this in the literature think
that this discount rate is inimical to
our future survival and I think that's
right here that much about people far
away then then you act the way we are
now which is living for the moment and
our future generations and possibly the
next generation be dead right
and that's deeply problematic and one
could ask is humanity worth surviving
that's another level up but if you care
about humanity we spent that okay or
descendants I mean good thing ever the
pro octopus person would say no again
man I do be damned like I've met people
who think that it's better not to have
humanity around yes in all seriousness
but not like them under the bus some
bridges I'm not gonna cross but okay yes
but I just think that we I've just sort
of putting this out there maybe I said
it before in the podcast I I I do think
that I'm sympathetic to the idea that we
should care more
yeah we empirically do about people for
awaiting people in the future yes I am
but I'm not sympathetic to the idea that
we should care about everyone equally
right no matter where they are when they
are I think that it's sort of
mathematically ill-defined yes is that
sure you know I think that there is a
there's a practicality issue you know
yeah there is I don't have any $5,000
suits but right I certainly am NOT
giving away all of my worldly goods in
the way that would best benefit mankind
yeah I think that you know it's kind of
impractical to imagine people doing that
there is something to be said for
balancing being good to the world of
being good to yourself I I fully agree
and and in fact I'm gonna forget the
name of the philosopher as Canadian has
written this paper on the paradoxes that
arise from zero discounting and there
are many yes it's not practical in many
of the same ways that Peter singers
approach so being the temporal version
has inherits it seems some of the same
paradoxes that the spatial version that
Peter Singer pushes but I get it as
there's as limiting concepts no you're
reminding us how far away we are from
that ideal it's very useful yeah yeah I
mean I think if we even went one tenth
of the way we would do much much better
then okay so how can we get people to
better I mean this is the practical yeah
well you do get people to be better at
taking the futures here exactly so my
initial thought was maybe if I could
really quickly figure out what was going
on in the brain to support the horizon
we have I could just invent a prosthetic
that everybody put on and suddenly
they'd be like taking the recycling out
pill you know or pill I subsequently
decided that neuroscience proceeds to
slowly that was my naive optimistic self
ten years ago and now I'm now now you
know the leading climate people say we
have a decade to two decades to really
do something or else it's catastrophe
I believe that's correct so I've been
pursuing cultural technology to try to
address the problem and it was inspired
by a book called the myth of the
rational voter yeah
by Kaplan and in that book he talks
about the concept of rational
irrationality the customer rational
rationality is that if the belief if
false belief the cost of false belief is
low then you're gonna have irrationality
so it's sort of an economist take on
epistemology step low cost high
irrationality and so that got me
thinking well how can we make something
that is outside of our perceptual bound
outside of our sensory envelope that we
really ought to care about how can we
make it real how can we give get what is
sometimes referred to as skin in the
game for something like that and so
myself and a couple collaborators Moran
Cerf at Northwestern have been pursuing
a study which we just completed a little
over 150 people participated half of the
more climate denial s and half of them
were believers in climate change where
we have them play a climate prediction
market that we created so there are bets
over a period of 30 days on things like
well California have more wildfires in
the coming month and they did a year ago
at the same time and whole bunch of
things like that and people got $20 of
money to play this market and you know
if they do really well they could
potentially earn a decent amount from
the study and so we just finished it
actually weeks ago we haven't we've
collected we've got all the data sewn up
and we're can't I can't wait to get back
to to analyze it I'm there's a number of
things I'm excited about one is that I
do think that you know there's this
issue of well how much in the next 30
days can you say is actually due to
climate change and so on and so forth
that's how there are any questions
they're there however there are other
things that lead me to think that this
could be successful regardless of
whether or not that's
for example as a result of this sports
betting there's been a lot of research
on what does what effect does sport
betting have on people's behavior oh
yeah and the data is clear it more the
triples participation now causality
there is unclear right so if you're a
sports buff then perhaps you're gonna
watch
you're gonna both that and watch three
times more NFL games which is what the
data show but there seems to be a huge
engagement effect once you bet money on
something happening on an outcome you
get engaged and we just like people to
get engaged with climate knowledge
climate information so one of the
questions we asked in our survey pre and
post study survey is how many climate
related stories did you attend to in
your media you know escape before and
after the study so we'd like to see
whether this engagement effect which
would be quite different from you know
whether or not you get skin in the game
effects so as I recently came across a
study it was not that but similar and I
actually found through another podcast
berkelium has a high five podcast high
pH I philosophy haha and so he quotes
this study I think it's by Bullock but
okay I'll get the reference and I'll put
it on the website it was you know
there's this very well-known difference
in beliefs about certain factual things
behind Democrats and Republicans haha
servers liberals like did the budget
deficit go up or down during the Clinton
presidency right it's a fact everyone
knows there there's a number what do you
think the number is and there's a gap
and they said okay as I give the survey
just some people and they see what the
gap is and then they give the survey to
another bunch of people and they say
we'll give you a dollar if you get the
answer right yeah and suddenly the gap
goes away yes basically yeah people are
much better there's an expressive
component yes to giving you opinions
about things like that even when they're
facts and when you actually put the skin
in the game
yeah charging him a dollar well then
they're more likely together you're
probably aware of this so Hanson who
came up one of the people who came up
with prediction market obviously Robin
Hanson at George Mason has tons of tons
of examples of this where it seems to
take a trivial
money right to actually close that gap
so it's almost like it's unlinked from
the monetary value just the fact that
you have any actually causes a huge
change in your epistemology ya know I
said earlier with this from playing
poker
because poker is the most boring game in
the world if you're not playing for
money yeah yeah just do whatever
yeah like play for a couple of pennies
and like well that's a fabulous metaphor
for people's position on climate change
that's right yeah so okay so I can see
how putting a little bit of skin in the
game makes people act a little bit more
rationally how do we implement that to
save the planet well so the idea would
be if we could say universalize such a
market suppose this is tiny 1% tax
carbon tax and it goes to people being
able of playing is this carbon or on
this prediction market yeah it has a
huge number of beneficial effects one
effect would be that you'd get wisdom of
the crowd effects so there's a whole
bunch of things happening to the climate
right now that a very very small subset
of which are being attended to by
scientists things like for example ice
roads in Alaska having to close much
earlier than normal things like my
friend and Pasadena's Garden is being
overtaken by this invasive species that
likes warmer climates you know the whole
line industry is changing that there's
that making champagne in Britain there's
that so so all of these you can create
these positions on the market and now it
becomes an instrument by which we can
see what climate change effects are
occurring and it becomes a sort of a
prosthetic if you will for understanding
what changes are occurring over what
timescale and that the the market might
be a means by which we achieve our
behaviors to longer temper all sort of
but are you imagining essentially
forcing people to play in this market or
bribing them to do it
I suppose I haven't thought that far in
advance but if one could universalize
the market and have a small amount of a
carbon tax go into everybody's pocket
and they could either just leave it
there as sort of direct profit or they
could play this market and possibly
amplify based on their knowledge then
the people who want to play the market
will will do so and those who don't mean
it relies on the idea that in some sense
we have the cognitive capacity to plan
for in the future and get it right but
there are sort of shortcuts that we
often take that prevent us from doing
precisely right that I feel we need to
bring it into we need to bring these
very slowly looming phenomena be they
climate change or a future AI we need to
bring it into the planning range our
native planning range and the mechanism
for that would be to change the costs so
to make it costly not to right right you
need to destroy that would ya change the
incentive structure but in a way that we
can sort of get our arms around spatial
temporally speaking and I feel like a
prediction market would be one way it's
probably just one of many ways just the
first one that we thought was worth
testing but there are other approaches
and the principle is basically get skin
in the game yeah as in your skin now
during your life for something that
might otherwise you know take very very
long a very very long time which is the
obvious example of our failure to think
on long horizons but my favorite example
is actually solar flares if you're very
familiar with this idea but heard you
talk about this yes well I had a lunch
with a lawyer who was on some committee
to look at this like he's not a
scientist or an engineer but like he got
the expert testimony yes and the claim
which I'm still not sure I haven't
really dug into the evidence for it
myself but the claim was look solar
flares happen all the time but really
big ones are rare uh-huh we're not sure
how rare because we have not been
collecting data for solar flares for
that long right it is absolutely
possible that on timescales of once per
every thousand years we get a solar
flare that will be big enough to
essentially wipe out the
our power grid of the earth millions and
millions of people would die yes it'd be
without power for months or some yes
right and it's not that costly compared
to the downside to harden the grid and
say seeing this I say no one is gonna
pay the money to do that where I say
there's a 1000 writings per year the
Pacific Assam yes we just can't do that
calculation right good at it yeah it
needs to have happened at least once in
the modern period yeah
so our day we're just nothing in
evolution ever trains you to play in on
timescales 10 times longer than a human
life doesn't for obvious reason right
right
I wonder if that's maybe that's a good
Planet of the Apes movie I think that's
I think things like that are because you
know scare people a little bit is useful
if it's a good scare like it right China
Syndrome was kind of silly but and Day
After Tomorrow was kind of silly for
different reasons but yes we can we can
apply art and culture yeah yeah do that
yeah which reminds me we'll end the the
podcast by because people need to know
this you are the science adviser on a
very well known culturally important TV
show Caprica
Caprica that's like I'm not sure yes not
sure if it falls into all those
categories but yes
that was that was a great experience
being able to go through every script
and be part of be a part of that show do
you think that there is value or how
much value you think there is in
scientists engaging and that kind of
engagement with popular culture it's not
outreach in the sense that you know
you're not learning neuroscience from
watching Caprica right right but maybe
by nudging the script in certain ways
you're inspiring people what does your
thought about that yeah I think that
there's lots of ways in which it
enriches the shows and and in particular
you know this the script writers aren't
you notice they're well trained in
science typically not and so when they
are thinking about how do I portray this
AI breakthrough or this robot assist
they're gonna take off things from the
shelf which you know are probably things
that they saw in movies and and
stereotypes that they
from pop culture actually and and don't
track with what is a much more
interesting and fine-grained sort of
thing that's going on in reality and so
what we're able to do is sort of add
some nuance there and but also I mean
there's the great thing about Caprica
has had lots of interesting
philosophical aspects to it you know
this whole sort of going into VR and the
concept of having I remember talking
with the show writers for a long time
about how do we have death in VR and
that was a really fascinating problem to
puzzle over and eventually decided on
something like a game that you got
kicked out of once he died yeah and it
was it was a real it was a really
important game because this is in the
context of the show it's the one game in
which this person could see their
daughter who died and now lives in this
virtual reality and so getting kicked
out of show really meant something very
meaningful right and did the influence
flow the other way did working on
Caprica in any way influenced you to
think deeply about looming AI menace
yeah well about takeover you know I
think that Battlestar Galactica and
Caprica did an amazing job of envisaging
this this this whole arc right and
there's these beautiful moments of
Battlestar for example where the Cylons
one of the Cylons a goes boomer says you
know I'm not sure humanity has a right
to continue existing and and and and
just pushes on both challenge for us it
is a good little challenge and and I
feel like the way they envisioned
envisaged are sort of moral prospects
with AI was fascinating and and deeply
thought-provoking one so yes well we do
hope that your work and the work of
others we've had on the podcast will
help stave off the Cylons from taking
over at some point nothing we've ever
thanks so much for being upon it it's
great to be on the show thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]